health experts are worried the political
rhetoric around
a vaccine could affect people's
willingness to be inoculated
when it finally becomes available our
lead national correspondent david
begneau is following this
david how close are we to a vaccine
so anthony there are three vaccines in
phase three of the clinical trials here
in the us and about 46 000
americans are participating in them now
phase three is the final process
so determining what comes out of there
figuring out if it's effective and good
data
the last step would be approval
i think knowing that a vaccine is this
close to being approved
is really exciting and really promising
37-year-old natalie hayden
is a mother of two from st louis
missouri she is one of millions of
americans with an
underlying health condition which means
she is at higher risk to get really sick
if she develops the coronavirus
treatments for crohn's disease have
weakened her immune system
she didn't leave home for months at the
start of the pandemic
she says a vaccine would be a lifeline
for her and her family
do you plan to get a vaccine when it's
available i'm a little bit apprehensive
about getting the vaccine but i do think
in the end i will be getting it it is
already september so when i think about
possibly having a vaccine approved by
the end of the year that seems
super fast and maybe a bit rushed i
wouldn't probably take it just yet in
the next few months
natalie is not alone in feeling that way
americans are growing increasingly
skeptical about a potential vaccine the
latest cbs news poll
shows that just 21 say they'll get the
vaccine as soon as one is available
that is down from 32 percent in july but
experts say the science behind the
vaccine
has been very sound it has gone
incredibly fast but it's been done with
integrity
that is dr ashish shah dean at brown
university school of public health
he's worried that months of hard work on
vaccines could be compromised
by political pressure being placed on
the fda
and by campaign politics affecting
people's attitudes
about vaccine safety our national
response to this pandemic has
not been stellar on so many different
levels but the one area where we've
actually done a really good job is on
vaccines
i want to make sure we don't fumble at
the one yard line here we've got to keep
politics out of this
you think that folks on both sides
whether it be the biden camp and the
trump camp
dial it back i would like politicians
from all sides to stay out of it
not get involved not do political
meddling and really let the science
drive the timeline
you know dr zha was clear he said
everybody involved in the vaccine
process
including the white house has done an
outstanding job on vaccines
those are his words now he says we could
have a vaccine
by october maybe november or december
he's thinking later in the year after
the election
but the bottom line gail is even once we
pass that approval process
dr josh says rolling this out to most
americans who want to get a vaccine
could go well into next year even the
summer
yeah but i find dr zhao very very
encouraging i think he always speaks
his mind i think he speaks very fairly
but i like what he said
the vaccine has been done with integrity
and let both sides sort of dial it back
always good to hear from him david good
to hear from you too wherever you are
thank you very much